good evening everyone and welcome to
this meeting of the northwest area
planning committee
held today in this council chamber on
the 8th of september 2021. my name is
councillor maddie thompson i'm the
chairman of this committee
before we commence the business of the
meeting there are a few housekeeping
issues to run through
in case i forget it in the event of a
fire a siren will sound please use the
fire exit marks with the green running
man ideally that one but obviously any
port in a storm because we're not
expecting a drill
members we're now working with the setup
for the meetings as agreed at council on
the 2nd of september most aspects are
back to the pre-covered normal however
some people will choose to wear a mask
we'll take other measures and i would
ask you all to respect that please
we're streaming this meeting live as
well as recording and by being present
in the meeting you are giving your
consent being recorded when invited to
speak please turn on your microphone
speak clearly referencing a page or
paragraph number when referring to
agenda papers keep your contributions as
clear and concise as possible and ensure
your microphones remain off when not
speaking as this is very important for
the live streaming so that it can be
heard clearly
finally can i draw your attention to the
notices on the agenda paper regarding
the different levels within the chamber
and the fire exit which i've just
mentioned
uh right
first our second item is apologies for
absence please mister
okay thank you chairman we have received
apologies from councillor jarvis and
councillor siddal thank you
right members the next item is the
minutes of the last meeting they are
found on pages 7-15
um
i
they need to be approved as a true and
accurate record or amend it
appropriately
iso move do i have a secondary
okay counselor key seconded right any
matters of accuracy
counselor stevens
thank you chair
the um item number 147 disclosure of
interest on the third um paragraph there
says that i was an acquaintance of the
officer it's actually that i'm an
acquaintance of the architect
okay thank you members you're happy to
accept that as an amendment
great okay so with that amendment we can
agree the minutes by ascent thank you
thank you councillor
okay item four declarations of interest
i'm afraid i have to read all this to
disclose the existence and nature of any
disclosable pecuniary interests other
pecuniary interests or non-pecuniary
interests relating to items of business
on the agenda having a regard to
paragraphs six to eight inclusive of the
code of conduct for members and members
are reminded they are required to
disclose any such interests if they
should become aware during the meeting
ladies first council fleming
thank you chair non-pecunory as a member
of essex county council who are
consultees
in planning matters and then also i
wanted to declare that
i have met this gentleman here i've
spent
some time down at blue house farm
with the north hambridge parish council
we went to have a look at the site and
the scheme thank you thank you
councillor
thank you chairman and non-pecuniary
interest as a member of essex county
council because they are the lead flood
authority which is relevant in this case
thank you
thank you very much anybody else not
seeing anybody else thank you so item
five is the actual planning applications
um i think this would be a good time as
i've just been reminded for the planning
officers to introduce themselves so
mr jones
no i'm my name is michael johnson i'm
the lead specialist development
management thank you thank you and ms
matthews
good evening members thank you um
chairman i'm catherine mathews i'm the
case officer for the application
and i'm working in development
management thank you okay
we do have a member of the public to
speak following the presentation so
could we start with that
thank you chairman uh this is an
application for um proposed deepening of
a 20 22 hectares part of the nature
reserve
for the wetland scrape in three
locations the construction of a raised
footway screening buns a base for a
wildlife hide and areas above the water
line for roosting and nesting birds
along with the installation of uh two
kilometers of anti-predator fence to a
height of one point eight meters to
replace an existing anti-predator fence
so the location of the site is outlined
in red on the screen there
and the nearest residential property is
to the northwest at the end of franklin
road which is roughly where that happens
to be that orange circle on the on the
plan
um means of access to the site is via
um
blue house farm chase which is to the
west of the site
and then you've got the river crouch
just peeping up there on at the bottom
of that slide
a wider view showing where the
application site is in relation to the
the rest of the nature reserve outlined
in blue and the village north land
bridge to there to the right there to
the left sorry
the same information again really but
just a different vantage point
let's try a keyboard
right so this is um a layout of the of
the site um
actually before i go any further i just
wanted to um remind members that there
is an update for this application and
which was previously circulated
and a uh one further verbal update um in
that they we have heard i have heard
back from natural england
and they have confirmed that a habitat
regulation assessment would be required
um which i have done and sent to natural
england
so this is the um the layout of the site
and you've got the three pink
circles there which would be the scraped
areas within which there would be raised
areas islands
and then you've got the pros walkway
which is that red line coming in from
the
from the west and towards um a central
area which would be where the raised
platform would be the bends would go
either side of that proposed walkway and
the predator fence will go around the
whole perimeter of the site
and so these are some cross sections
some typical cross sections so you've
got the um
showing the existing ground levels and
the top one would be this
showing what the cross-section of the
scrapes would be like in the middle one
you've got the cross-section of the
walkway
and the bottom one you've got a cross
section of the raised platform
and some typical photos of the site
oh
slight delay when i press the button
okay and this is just
to illustrate that there was a previous
area of the site where a similar
proposal for scrapes and
um
wildlife enhancement measures was
approved earlier this year the the
current application site is just to the
to the north of that red area there
so yeah so
so in conclusion the proposal is
considered to be acceptable in principle
and would not cause harm to the
character appearance of the area or the
immunity of local residents subject to
the imposition of conditions which are
recommended as part of the um the report
there are no no objections raised in
relation to the impact of the works on
flood risk or drainage um along with
highway safety
and access and the proposal would
actually result in enhancements in
relation to nature conservation on the
basis of that it's recommended that plan
permission is granted subject to
conditions as set out in our gender
paper thank you
thank you
all right members there is a members
update but we have mr album to speak
first i'm afraid i'm not sure sir if
you're the applicant or the agent
um
just please
you're the agent okay please use your
microphone we're just getting the clock
up so don't stop for a second
uh when you do the clock we'll start
when you begin to speak and you have two
minutes precisely and i'm afraid i never
let anybody go over
thank you chair
whoa whoa sorry
are we
thank you chair essex wildlife trust
welcome the opportunity to provide
further details on our planning
application the aim of this proposal is
to further enhance bluehouse farm nature
reserve in north fanbridge
this nate's conservation project will
complement the existing habitats not
only at blue house farm but will be
functionally linked to the neighboring
designated sites and nature reserves in
the river crouch and estuary
essex wildlife trust and the rspb are
partners delivering the essex wader
strategy with the aim of reversing
declines of nationally threatened
breeding waders in essex and in the east
of england blue house farm has a key
part to play in that strategy
there will be very little change to the
character of the site from what you can
see today the area known as round marsh
has been holding water for many years
attracting birds and other wildlife
the works will enable water to be held
air in areas that are currently dry
and they dry out early in the breeding
season and provide much needed
protection from predators
this will enable greater numbers of
breeding wages to thrive any concerns
over flooding of neighbouring land are
shared between us ewt have always been
confident the proposal would not create
an increased flood risk that's been
confirmed by the project's flood risk
assessment as part of the application by
retaining more winter water this will in
fact take pressure off the surrounding
ditch system and river system by
increasing drainage capacity in times of
increased water levels
for the duration of the project there
will be limited movements of
construction vehicles impacting on the
community in the surrounding road
infrastructure
all excavated materials have been
designed into the project with the
material being used to create areas for
feeding roosting birds and areas from
which to view them and finally this
wonderful nature reserve is and will
continue to be not only a place where
nature can thrive but a place where
people can thrive too in a changed world
evidence continues to show that a
natural environment rich in nature
benefits the mental and physical health
of local communities thank you
thank you and what excellent timing
um
right members before we move to a
proposal i'm going to ask if there are
any questions or items of discussion
you'd like to raise um and then
presumably uh when we've done that we'll
move to a proposal councillor white um
thank you madam chairman um i'd like to
thank um mr alton because i also got an
invite um but unfortunately i faced
clark and did some hard course i
couldn't actually
go anywhere but i do know the site very
well and i've been involved with it i
knew the owners before
and i i always bring these forward
because i'm always a bit wary of them um
you know just digging into the ground
i'm always a bit wary but i approve the
last ones that's fine um my i'm a bit
surprised really i might have misheard
the officer's presentation
um because it sounded like mdc had sent
in the hra whereas i understood that was
for the applicant to do so i wondered
who did it and if the authority sent it
in and why they did
and my view is that this should be
deferred until natural england have
consulted because we have one of the
best areas of grassland
in the uk for brent geese and which we
do free of charge for nature so we work
very closely with the directors of
natural england and i understood
could be wrong that hras had to be
approved and
commented on by
natural england um and i just think that
we really should take the view i'm sure
they won't have a problem once they've
read it but i just think if we're going
to be mindful um we should get that
double checked first because i
understood they had to um
approve them um before going ahead with
any work
um
could i have the answers first to the
question ms matthews and then we'll move
on to whether approval is uh deferral is
appropriate or i would have thought more
likely conditioned that it had to be
impro approved before the planning
application was
finalized so ms matthews okay thank you
chairman um
the requirement for doing the um
the hra habitat regulation falls with
the council um as the competent
authority in in these matters um
very sometimes the um applicant can um
submit their own
um
i don't know that's why it's checking
ahead and their own
hra but
in this case the competent authority
would be the the district council it
does vary depending on the particular
proposal and who's responsible um
but
in this case and and natural england
have advised the same that is it is mdc
responsibility to do complete and hra in
consultation with natural england um
yes and the answer to the second
question is that
yes the
hra would need to be approved by natural
england um
before the plan any planning permission
is is actually issued thank you thank
you that's right
if i might come back so are we saying
that we've actually paid for because it
has to be done as far as i'm aware by a
qualified um ecologist
am i right in thinking that modern
district council have paid for this to
be done i'm a bit perplexed really i'm
like oh
no one's paid anyone other than than me
as part of my job it's quite common
and and planning officers do the hra but
as i say in consultation with natural
england um we've done quite a few of
them now over the years and um
they
they do follow with a pretty standard
format but um
but no it
the planning officers do them um and
they get signed off by um management um
as i say
for these particularly sensitive sites
in in consultation with natural england
but the others on the smaller sites um
where natural england aren't directly
involved then
um moulding council would do them and
sign them off themselves thank you
council tyler
thank you thank you chairman
i don't have any problem with this
i'm slightly concerned about a six foot
high predator fence
thinking about that we only got badgers
and foxes there are any predators
so i'm gonna think twice about walking
around there if there's something that's
going to be um
possibly
needing to be kept out by those six
socks i'm pretty sure a fox can scale a
six foot fence it depends on the fence
okay badger i'm not so sure no i don't
see many budget and anyway um but no so
chairman i i'm quite happy with it i
think it should be supported and i'm
happy to
propose uh that it is um it is approved
this evening
all right we have a step up
recommendation proposed by councillor
dharam seconded by councillor keys but
council fleming you have a question
i mean this is the point where we moved
to the debate now we have a proposal on
the table so thank you chair not not a
question actually it was just responding
to councillor durham's
question about the predator fence my
understanding it's for foxes
they can scale those heights
okay would anyone like to speak either
for or against the proposal
sorry i've got councillor steve so we'll
come back to you councillor white but
you you've had one go
sorry so are we saying that the fence
isn't high enough because i hadn't
really thought about the height of the
fence i just thought the height was the
right height
are we now saying it's too short
no no i think the query was it sounds
alarmingly high for a little fox
but actually they can manage six feet
and
i'm pretty sure that the essex world
live trust knows what kind of fence it
needs unless anyone else has
professional knowledge to the contrary
um sorry we're actually i
apologize mr alton but
we don't do this or we'd never get any
meetings finished so i'm sure you can
have a quick chat
i'm pretty sure you could have a quick
chat afterwards if that made you feel
better okay miss white does that answer
your
question
the only one i wanted was to make sure
that the hi was accepted and also make
sure that it's down to the authority to
do it i'm really surprised when we've
had to do them it's always been the
applicants that's had to do them we've
never had the authority do one for us um
so i'm just a bit surprised so it could
be me that's wrong you know i fully
accept that but it just seems very
strange that we're paying for it i think
this is worth addressing outside the
meeting if you have concerns um
but
i understand that it does depend
somewhat on the sort of application it
is
i'm just googling it here and it's like
we're putting in all the mitigation
measures under the hra that the
authority authority's going to be
putting all the mitigation in in case
there's any harm so i'm just reading um
about who does hre that that's all and
it's also got to be monitored apparently
as well
okie doke
is that sorry i have read all this but
retaining it is another thing ms
matthews is that included as a condition
or is that an assumed condition
sorry the hra yes
um no that's sort of a separate um
report if you like to the um the um
agenda report but um
um the suggestion that that the
permissions should be
um held on to and until natural england
have given the thumbs up to the
the hra is is the correct procedure to
go through yeah right
um on that basis are we happy to go to
the vote members so could we have
show of hands in favor of the
recommendation to a program put mine in
there that does seem to be unanimous
thank you very much
so the
application is approved in line with the
offices report thank you very much
everyone the only other item is
other items of business the chairman's
decides are urgent there are none so
number seven members and officers thank
you very much for your contributions
this evening i draw the meeting to a
close at 7 7.47
i think that's a record